thằng tại khu vực biệt giới thái lan cậpu chia đã mùng phát thành đồng độ vú trang.
Cô nội thái lan cho biết đã có ý nhất,
mười hai người thiệt mạng và nhiều người khác bị thường.
Chúng tôi nghĩ đó phía cậpu chia sát nhận con năm quên dân thường bòng.
Chí vụ cậpu chia đã quyết định hả cấp quan hệ ngoại giao với thái lan xuống cấp bị thử thứ 2,
và châu hội tòàn thế, nhân viên ngoại giao đã là việc tại đại xu quán ở cậpu chia.
Đại xu quán cậpu chia ở mang có phy nước,
trước đó thì tôi đứng lâm thời thái lan,
tôi thích thông tham, quyết trả giả trái đã chiều hội đại xu thái lan tại các buồn chia về nước,
và yếu cầu đại xu quán cậpu chia, giời khỏi thái lan.
Đồng thời giới mạng sẽ xem sét khi hơn mức độ quán hệ sống phật.
Chí có việc chúng thích ASEAN năm hành nhiên không chăm hai bây lâm
tụ tưởng mà lại chia, anh Washington, y-brah hymn.
Đà kêu qua các bên mình tính và thông báo kêu hệ diện đảm bối tụ tưởng thái lan và các buồn chia.
Và tối này, để kêu hỏi hai nước giải quyết chanh chấp mành bị pháp hoặc mình.
Người phát ngôn bộ ngoài rau Trung Quốc, Quách Già Côn, đã mầy tò lo ngại về tìa hiện nay,
và cho biết sánh sản đống một vài cho trong việc hại nhạc cần tham.